ما قالت صحيفه واشنطن بوست عن مسؤولين
امريكيين ومصادر مطالعه قولهم من
ويليامبرز مدير وكاله الاستخبارات
المركزيه الامريكيه سافر سرا الى اوكرانيا
نهايه الاسبوع الماضي لاطلاع الرئيس
الاسكي على توقعاته لخطط روسيا العسكريه
في الاسابيع والاشهر القادمه
والغربيه بعد سيطره الجمهوريين على مجلس
النواب وقالت واشنطن
ومساعده
قويا وان مبلغ 45 مليار دولار من التمويل
الذي اقره الكونجرس سيستمر على الاقل حتى
يوليو او اغسطس المقبل كما نقلت الصحيفه
عن مصادرها ان كيف ليست متاكده من
احتمالات تمرير الكونغرس لحزمه مساعدات
تكميليه اخرى
فعلت في الربيع الماضي وانا مدير وكاله
الاستخبارات المركزيه الامريكيه اقرها
بدوره بانه سيكون من الصعب الحصول على
المساعده في مرحله ما